the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license
your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
ok so yesterday we went through quantum
mechanics and discussed solutions of the
Schrodinger equation we started with a
one-dimensional problem is a quantum
well two dimensional problem now we call
it a quantum wire and then say you can
extend that to a 3d that's easy and then
I give hang wave and solution for the
harmonic oscillator I give you the
result but I said I have my way to solve
it and then I don't have a way to solve
rigid rotor my way you can find it and
the electronic we give the results right
and in fact I said that you can also do
it iconic I know that you can do and
they find out so for different problems
the difference is really the potential
in the Schrodinger equation plus a
boundary condition that gave determined
why some are for this solution like
quantum well the energy level is
proportional n square the harmonic
oscillator is a proportional to n and
the electrons in atoms is a 1 over N
squared those are there because the
constraint of different shapes of the
potentials and why we discussed 1d and
2d problems the important info say
message we get is if it's a 1 degree of
freedom 1 dimensional problem we have
one quantum number and 2 dimensional
problem will have two quantum numbers
and three dimensional problem
like atoms will have three quantum
numbers and of course later on we add a
spin because that's not something you
can get from the Schrodinger equation
and then say quantum state is say each
set of a unique combinations of this
quantum numbers give you one quantum
state the problem is sometimes different
quantum state have the same energy so
when we can't we say when still have
same different states have same energy
in those states are degenerate and we
can count the degeneracy of the states
and those are later on important because
essentially when we do the car number of
particles like we did in first chapter
first two lectures we need us counting
we need to do the counting correctly so
degeneracy is later I'm going to be
warped into a density of states and spin
and Samsung we cannot easily say say we
cannot get from Schrodinger equation you
have to go to relativistic and but they
for electrons it's a half spin positive
mass one-half and those are fermions and
photons photons molecules the uncharged
are bosons and for fermions the Pauli
exclusion principle says each quantum
state can have maximum of one particle
so if it's a fermion particle each
quantum state can only have one to the
maximum okay empty right empty or what
so that's easy to come and for boson
each quantum state can have in front
number so this is a when you think about
this homologous oscillator the energy is
n times
H bar and C H bar mu H bar Omega right
the N could be zero one two or three
those those are save many C n numbers so
this is what we talked about and in
those examples the wave function are
confined right when I have quantum well
or quantum wire the wave function is in
this space that have been discussing
when have a atom the wave function is
limited to surrounding the nuclei so
oscillator that's the local right so
this is a what we discussed so far and
today where I'm going is I'm going to
put the atoms together right to have
solid crystals and how I'll see this
putting them together how they will
change the energy states in what we
discussed so what are we going to
discuss today is the energy levels in
solids
particularly our focus on electron today
and hopefully by the end of the lecture
you will appreciate why we have metals
we have semiconductors we have
insulators right these are all daily
encounters but until you have this
quantum picture you really can explain
and so we have metals semiconductors and
insulators right and one very useful
mathematical theorem that I introduced
today is the so-called block theorem
it's a it's a this is a theorem that
applies when the potential is a periodic
so when I deal with crystals the atoms
are arranged in periodic fashion and
because of this pure D City I can solve
the problem even though the crystal is a
ideal crystal is a unit a periodic
arrangement of atoms and because of
appeared yesterday I can fold all the
problems into one period and that's a
very beautiful okay and in fact the
block theorem is valid for all waves or
purity the structure say well you have
wave propagating inside and when you
deal with the heat conduction equation
or when you deal with the transport when
there is a temperature gradient this is
a lot longer valid or diffusion right
and therefore several years I've been
trying to say what's a corresponding
serum in the diffusion regime and
because when I do a composite and those
kind of full
problems transfer problems a compositor
has many many different materials think
about two a and B right
my simplest is I think a unit Co can I
solve that unit cell problem and yet to
be represented that I'm dealing with the
whole structure right so those are the
things that good question to ask and so
let's start we say we're dealing with
electrons right and in the last lecture
yesterday we deal with the electron when
we say our model is I have Adam and I
have electron right if you recall at the
end we show the wave functions we show
them computer the different equals one
safe example the wave function when
three quantum number one zero zero and
of course electron spin right that's N
equals 1 l equals 0 M equals 0 right a
swing functions is the lowest energy
level spherical wave function their
church here ok right and so this is a
question you can have higher other sig
wave functions the combinations and now
my question is what about this is a
simple you think about hydrogen atom
what happens to a hydrogen molecule when
I put a two atoms close together right
so in the case of single atom I have
this N equals one energy level and N
equals two right in the hydrogen model
we have the energy is degenerate the
minus thirteen point six the electron
volts over N square right 13 six
thirteen point six electron volts is
also another energy unit sometimes
people uses a readable one readable okay
and so this is a way of course where we
say degenerate because I have a three
quantum number and LM and plus the spin
quantum number right so if I have one
hydrogen atom I say atom the electron is
sits in the lowest energy level and now
if I put a two hydrogen atoms so I have
one hydrogen atom those are the electron
wave function right if you record the
spherical
alright and I have another so this is
one hydrogen atom and I have a letter
hydrogen atom an electron is spherical
wave function now when they interact
with each other to form molecule the
electron wave functions start overlap
and the Pauli exclusion principle kick
cream you can't do that now the two
electron right each hydrogen has white
life on the two electron cannot have the
same wave function because to say the
poly exclusion in one quantum state
doesn't take two electrons so what
happens and they will have to modify
that quantum state and split it and the
splitting gives you if you go to solve
the C wave function you off say okay
this is the day Adam say hydrogen atom
in one case it's a wave function is more
each one separated from each other and
the other case this is this wave
function is the probability of finding
electrons remember right if you do
complex conjugate and the other case you
have the wave function more surrounding
Li right this is a
Sigma bonds covalent bonding and that's
a the strongest the lower-energy this is
the anti bounce sig Sigma star higher
energy so what happens is that this
energy single energy of our atom now
because the cal poly exclusion principle
when they have two electrons for the
identical states they can't do it so
they split into two small with the
separation of the two energy levels
right so this states split into from one
to two okay so the this is a higher
energy level this lower energy level now
with this I can ask the question what if
I put the hydrogen atom into a Qin not
just a molecule right and if I have any
hydrogen atom what's going to happen
right there captain not at this mall if
I have capital n atoms what's going to
happen to n cross 1
right is split into energy levels right
and similarly anchors to so basically if
I have you will have under split into
each of the source playing through an
energy level right and now of course
that depends on here is how large is
this spread and this tool could actually
overlap right this is originally
thirteen point six eight divided by n
square so this is a few you be right if
this brilliant star the overlap with
each other
you have almost continuous right this
those are relative small level
separation between energy levels right
so this gives us the precursor to what
happens if I have say one-dimensional a
timeless chain so christos let's take a
bigger right
so my simplest picture is a one
dimensional arrangement crystals are the
pure original atoms so I have Heretic
arrangement of atoms and the potential
is a periodic so around the each atom
the electron recall the Coulomb
potential is negative C over R right so
here in the when I close to atom the
furniture is lowest and the in between
is a higher potential so I have here a
potential field to the charge right so
now we want to find out we say with a
radical some idea this is what's going
to happen the energy is going to split
and we want to find the splitting energy
levels okay
and we're going to solve the Schrodinger
equation for that and in fact that there
are really this this problem you can
look at the front three pictures
let me explain briefly the first picture
I already said the atomic orbital
overlapping so if I draw if I simplify
this potential right I give a square
rather than what I drew a one over our
okay so here I have lowest so this is
the day periodic that's that's another
way I model those potential the real
Adam is never just so this square it's
like I say this is very much depend on
the energy level depends on the
potential shape and of course if I do a
square then I have the picture I have
quantum Wells right if it's an infinite
potential I have this standing wave for
electrons quantum Wells and let's see
this is a normally nada infinite right
there certain height so it turns out
from we mechanics perspective say later
on when we do a chapter 5 you'll see the
wave can tunnel from one side to the
other so they start talking overlapping
and then quantum mechanic policy
exclusive principles say you can't
overlap the quantum state I say so they
were splitted this this was split into
again the ones that we described here
when atom of those start the overlap and
this are the ones this is a one picture
I say ok we start thinking about the
quantum well picture right and the other
picture is I have free electron moving
in space ok
and when free like from moving in space
and when it start to see so those are
the electron with the higher energy they
start to see a bumpy potential
underneath it pure article bumpy
potential underneath it right and in
that case what happened if you some of
you may have the experience using the
interference filter in your lab optical
interference filters in your lab right
so that's an optical wave comes in and
in the furnace pewter is a typical
particle layer deposition with different
refractive index so what happens is then
some of the wave would transmit through
others reflect back that's why I say you
can get lateral lines in the furnace
filter so the reflected back ones are
the one that do not exist say those are
the ones a wave cannot exist so this is
the gap here in the solid okay this is a
what what this leads to is a
semiconductor with the band gap okay and
so you have this two picture and the
third picture is what I'm going to
actually solve I solve the Schrodinger
equation another solution tells us what
are the energy level and all this will
converge into what we said already so
here I have the this is the pure D city
T right and let's say under my picture
here I'm going to take a wine uniseal
one pure I'm trying to solve the
Schrodinger equation in that fear right
I can take any pure so I put my
coordinate here is my origin of the
coordinate and this is zero and this is
the X direction and here is a and here
is let's say because this is on the
other side is minus P okay and from
minus P to a that's a ad to get
my pure tea right and I want to solve
the Schrodinger equation in this one
pure but I want to represent the whole
structure is a periodic my potential is
repeating every from every - B - a right
so here the potential is at the bottom
let's say the petitioner zero here the
potential is U 0 right so for a electron
in one region 0 potential the other
energy is user of potential and now I
want to say what are the allowable
energy levels of this electron in such a
periodic potential this is my question
ok so I will have to write down the
Schrodinger equation for each region
between 0 a the potential row and be the
negative V 2 0 is potential u 0 so I
have two different regions one is and
minus AE plus I equals zero right and
the other is so this is a bit 10 for X
between a and 0 the other is a for X
between 0 and negative B and in that
region my Schrodinger equation is a - M
psi the X square my + u 0 minus EE
beside equals 0 so I have two regions
and of course I need a boundary
conditions and I and what I am curious
in still what are the energies of the
electron right so we solve this type of
problem in the last lecture
and here is a say five at a height
before we say for this there is infinite
so in that region the wave function is
zero but now I have final u0 so my wave
function is not 0 in this region so I'm
going to solve this the first one let's
write the equation
yesterday I was using small K but today
let me switch to capital K capital K is
a square wave function so this is a for
this region for return 0 and a ok and K
square is same notation I want the fund
if I put this together is 2 mu e divided
by H bar square that's K square all
right and I'm going to solve this you
know this solution already so in this
region 0 a mice wave function as
function of X is a exponential minus I K
capital K X plus B exponential plus I
capital K X
so this is a wine region that I'm
interested in zero to a the other region
is for a minus B to zero right if you
look at the equation there is a plus u
zero Massey right of course you can
rather also in two-legged here you can
do the shape but let me give my D low Q
square equals to M user of Massey e
divided by H square so K square is 2 mu
H square now is negative so my solution
my root then is a plus minus Q is
another plus minus I K right that's the
heuristic equation for this one and then
solution then is a exponential minus Q X
plus D exponential plus Q X right you
can write into I if you reverse E and
the you your choice doesn't matter at
the end annunzio consistent after your
mass you're following so what I want to
find out is actually this is my target
what are the energy of the electron
right it's an eigenvalue problem okay so
I need to look how those solution and
give a boundary condition to the problem
so that I can solve for you and surely I
want to solve for e right so what are my
boundary between minus B to a the
interface here between the two region x
equals zero there's a boundary right at
this location the wave function itself
has to be continuous and also I tell you
the derivative of wave function has to
be continuous
and I'm not going to demonstrate to
prove it but say basically if you see
your particle flux expression that we
had before if you require the particle
flux has to be continuous if you wave
function continuous your derivatives
also has to be continued so so my either
x40 what I have is this wave functions
continues right so on the two sides the
wave functions continues what I have I
have a a plus B equals C plus D now you
say I would require I will need four
boundary conditions right and either say
first order derivative has to be
continuous so what I have is I K and
mass a plus B that's the derivative at
the X squares for zero e course he'll
must say plus D this are they continue
'ti are the actual x equal to zero now I
have two boundary conditions
I need a two more right so this is the
where I mentioned at the beginning the
block theorem started kicking why the
problem is if I just write this two
boundary condition is just a single
interface it has it bears nothing to do
with the pure D city of the crystal now
if you go back to the potential the your
potential is a function of X of course
in the problem we have here is a step
function we use a square so it's a step
function right
in general any arbitrary function but
it's a periodic so you X equal to u Expo
tea right that's the pure DISA tea
so if you use this periodicity and you
go to the Schrodinger equation and you
ask what does this periodicity bring you
to the solution what's the requirement
for your solution and mathematically the
block theorem block proved that because
of this potential pure D city my wave
function so due to pure duty the wave
function has to be after the wave
function X plus T later so right so one
pure the later the same location is
related to the wave function of X
previous pure same location by I K
tensor T so this K is smoking and that's
the block theorem here and in fact I say
you can write this in more general term
and so here say this is a 1d and there
3d version which will come out later on
and this small K is a wave vector that
we'll discuss more later on that's why
I'm using capital K for this solution
and to distinguish from the small cake
with vector okay so what does this tell
us is I'm going to use a pure disa T now
I can look at this point right this
point and in the left hand side is my
solution between 0 to a
on the right-hand side is this point
this point is this one right
curiosity and I have solution for this
to this region
I have solution for this region so I
just need to relate through this
solution through the block theorem so
either X square to a I use the block
theorem X equal to a the block theorem
say the wave function is related and
also corresponding you take a derivative
derivative is also related okay so the
wave function is a in the in the first
region 0 to a you see we have that
solution is a exponential minus I Kappa
a ka plus be exponential positive of ka
right and this equal to exponential I K
small K times T that's the T equals a
plus B and then times the wave function
when X equal to minus B so if I do x
equals minus P in that region must be to
0 so when X equal to must be is a say
exponential QB plus D exponential mask
you'll be right so I got my third
equation and similarly if I take a
derivative I got my false equation so
this is the wave function block theorem
and derivative block theorem again so
derivative is if I take derivative you
can say there you cor so I have I K a
and a exponential master exponential I K
a class
be exponential plus K a this is captor
and equals exponential minus I K T and
you have a Q in the front and - say
exponential Q B plus D exponential plus
a negative Q B we're not going to do
more operation of this four equations
the point I want to make it if you look
at this it's a homogeneous equation no
constant right terms ABCD you have four
coefficients and all constant terms if
you move to the one side all constants 0
so this is a heuristic of eigen value
equations and you are if you if you have
homogeneous equation to have a long zero
solution ABCD your determinant must be
zero for linear equations right
everybody's following me the determinant
of 1 2 3 4 is zero if you see this is
determinant 0 you look at this capital K
is a function of energy right K is a
function of energy Yi and capital Q is a
function of energy so capital Q is a
function energy right so given given the
a given the B we know T and for each K I
have a solution for energy so this is
where my math will end up right so
because this is a homogeneous equation
my determinant must be 0
the coefficients you put all your
coefficients together and you will get
an equation that allow you to determine
the energy levels of the electron in
such a periodic potential okay so let me
do a few steps of math and if you do the
determinant you actually will get an
equation not that scary is a Q square
minus K square capital and the tool K
cube is cinch function hyperbolic sine
QB and sine real sine K a and plus cos
inch QV and the cosine capital K a on
the right hand side is a cosine small K
that's a wave vector a plus B that's the
pure this is the T okay so this is the
if you do your determinant of this for
equation there at the end you gather
this set of equation this equation here
in this equation Q has energy K has
energy and small K so for each K value
you can solve for that energy in the
equation okay and this still it's not
very graphic or mathematically it's
still too complicated so let me let me
make one more simplification for the
purpose of explaining this solution will
lead to the band gap in the material and
Bank gap is essentially if you think
about semiconductors or those right
so aha my last step is I let B goes to
zero but say I will keep a you times B
because when that B is zero this is a
very letter O say P is very loud so this
becomes very lair oh right and you times
to be finite
that also means the potential is going
to shoot up very high right but see the
with this if I say B goes to 0 Q tends
to be this guess to just approximate
that aq be yourself you ninny ur eyes it
so this this by that a QQ cancel so what
I have here I can write this P capital K
times a sine capital K times a and plus
cosine capital K times a equals cosine
ka because b is 0 so a itself is the
pure this city this is V vector this K
has energy and the P itself is it's just
a constant P here is a constant okay so
this one with this I can go say
graphically what this solution will look
like look like right you can say now the
left hand side is the cosine the maximum
is minus 1 to plus 1 the right hand side
I want to find the energy K right in
this capital K has energy capital K is a
2 m eh square okay so you can see this
is a butyl minus 1 to 1 and here is a
factor right when K a goes to 1 this
divided this sine X divided by X is 1
so the P plus so this could be larger
than one in that case there's no
solution
right there's no K capital K would
satisfy that so graphically if I do my
solution what it looks like so what I'm
going to draw here on the is as a
function of K a so here I have K capital
K a and because this is a little bit
difficult solve so here is that function
on the left hand side on the left hand
side is just you win sugar decrease into
cosine right okay
and on the so this is a KA and on the
right hand side is the range is minus
one to plus one so because I want to
find out one other solution K for that
include energy so this is the range
between minus 1 to plus 1 I'm not
drawing well so this is a positive 1
this negative 1 so that means when K in
this region
I have solution in this region I have
solution in this region I have solution
but as K becomes larger eventually this
is within minus 1 to plus 1 so I have
solution everywhere when this K a
becomes very large
tabes again energy so that means when
energy is very large I don't have
forbidden region but in this region
this is my forbidden I don't have any
energy in this region right this region
I don't have a solution okay so if I
replay this because what I'm saying here
is this region for any ka cosine this
small ka if you gave me a value of the
cosine in smoke hey I have a
corresponding energy solution right so I
can go replay that ka because this is a
pure article function so now this is a
capital K that gives me energy
my last days I'm going to plot this
function in small ka hope you don't get
confused okay I'm going to plot out what
the solution look like
and the solution is a say because this
is a cosine K a so it's a periodic so my
solution will look like this
and this is the energy and essentially
what that energy has is derived from K
right
this capital ka is in this region that's
the solution and so this is a if in this
region and in the Lexx region I don't
have energy this is a forbidden so I can
for the when in this region of energy
here there is no solution so there is a
gap here right because this is beyond
the one so what I have is next what it
looks like
okay
so in butane is a gap this is the gap
that I've been talking right that's the
corresponding to this region here I have
no solution low allowable energy
electron cannot have this energy in the
when they put in the pure this purity
structure okay so this is a my how the
solution will look like and the less
lived in here and they come back to look
at this wave vector what is the
allowable wave vector values right so
for the wave vector I have to go back to
the here this is the block theorem right
and so I need to decide what is the wave
vector and I know I have all atoms in
the crystal so between this one and the
capital n the total length of the
crystal right now the length of the
crystal is the young atoms times the
periodicity right and this pure disa T
in the limit I'm consider is n times a a
is in my pure right because the B is
zero okay so this is aware there is a
very interesting boundary condition
artificial sort of artificial boundary
condition that was introduced and this
boundary condition is this is a 1 this
is the N right that's a final ends
crystal right there is a final length
and from common introduced the purity of
boundary condition
okay now I'm going to write some comment
and what I say is because this n capital
n is usually very large it really
doesn't matter much and the one way to
do to say a purely boundary condition
say after this one to end the crystal
repeat itself so n plus one come back to
a to what okay so what is say the wave
function our for n plus 1 equals the
wave function of one first atom right
and you're real spaces are going from 1
to N and this is a coda from common
periodic boundary condition and what did
I tell us is when so what we have here
is say y when x equals n so what I have
is poss-eye
x plus na right that's the say length of
the crystal is equals cosine X here okay
and with that I will have
exponential I K times n a should equal
to 1 so this is the what a from common
purely boundary condition gives him and
it gives me way to say K equals 2pi and
a that's the length of the crystal and
times small N and this n is plus minus 1
plus months two and the plus months n
you continue okay now what it means is
this small K wave vector is not a
continuous function it has if you look
at this and when ever N equals the
length of the crystal right say N equals
capital n and I have the k a k times a
will repeat the two pipe right ok if you
look at that smoke a k times a when and
I say equals chapter and smoker and you
can tap the end that's two pipe right so
here what I have is this is 0 this is 2
pi and between K a u-turn 0 2 pi I have
really n points so I will have the
number of points is endpoints here and
is the number of atoms in the crystal
okay I think the other way I want to say
this they from common purely boundary
condition really doesn't matter
basically I have electrons that extend
the wave function is extended between 1
and n right I have a wave function in
the region I will say 0 to L because I
say this is my beginning they told L is
the total length right so now I ask you
if you know a function whatever function
between 0 and L X equal 0 to L right and
you know you can do a Fourier series
this is a disk this is a finite length
function right if you go recall your
Fourier series if you have function
between 0 to L you write into full
series Sam what is it to sign X right
any function return 0 to L you can
decompose into the series of sine and
cosine functions okay so let's write
that so I have in general any function I
can always write a 0 plus Sigma N equals
1 to infinite write a n cosine 2pi and
over LX + + b + sine 2pi and LX alright
that's any function as I'd say I know
this function between 0 to L I can
expand it in Sion cosine series
you're great so what does this tell me
if I write sine cosine in exponential is
say let's say a n complex and
exponential i 2pi and L X plus B and
complex and exponential mass I too high
and L X right I can rearrange and write
into exponential once I write into
exponential what does this mean is this
is the stationary part of the
Schrodinger equation right you remember
there's time-dependent exponential minus
I Omega T if I put a minus I Omega T
into this multiplied together this is a
wave propagating to the positive
x-direction this is a wave propagating
to the negative x direction right so I'm
a decomposing this wave function into
many modes right again the modes right
two pi NL ish n is one way one one
wavelength okay so I'm decomposing this
into many modes and so what I have is
every 2 pi I will have a captor a total
of all capital endpoints okay and it's
very important to understand this
counting so basically even though this
function I'm drawing is continuous and I
have many very closely spaced the points
as a wave vectors and the total between
0 to PI CK a 0 to pi is a capital n
point stays
okay so this is the representation in
terms of because it's erotic so now I
have the option because I don't want to
draw this so I can take a 0 to 2 pi can
do this that's enough
right but say even this is not a user
way to draw the band structure and in
fact I say people let them like to draw
0 2 pi
they like to draw 0 to PI and the 0 to
negative pi any 2 pi is fine right so I
can draw really between here and here
and forget the rest
and that's 1 and even this from ok from
negative PI to positive PI there again
there are n points right 0 to PI their
end points negative PI to the PI they're
also in point but say it's a symmetric
right the wave going forward positive x
direction negative x direction they are
symmetric right that's why my solution
positively k- k is symmetric so because
of that I only do 1/2 so 0 2 pi so
that's usually what you will say when
people plot the band structure and this
see what they will say is they don't
plot ka they will plot here 0 to PI so
it's a PI over a that's okay
wave vector and here is the energy and
this is the solution for whatever
potential in this specific pure decided
the ration of the crystal right I see
it's a 1d crystal right in real crystal
is every direction you okay you can say
okay I'm considered a pure yesterday in
that specific at the ration and that's
my way vector that's why now it's a
vector we vector Direction is along that
specific direction of the crystal and
then we were well we discuss in the next
lecture more on the crystal say geometry
is different geometry of crystal okay
remember here because it's a zero to PI
0 to PI only so they are really 1/2 n
right and over two points between 0 to
PI array because they're another half is
bitten on the other side right negative
side which I didn't draw okay so what
does it what's so special
out of this this are they electron
energy level and this is a so you have
this a semi continuous curve the curve
itself you draw continuous but because K
is discontinuous this area is also
really closely spaced by this continuous
point right what's the relation between
what we talked about for atomic orbital
at the beginning and roughly this band
is an equal one right if I think about
the hydrogen atoms the negative thirteen
point six and square right
this band is N equals one this is an
equal to now it's splattering too many
small levels right and then we see at
the beginning when we discuss hydrogen
if I have n atoms I have energy levels
now I have n points to turn negative PI
over a to plus PI over a so how an
energy level in each of this band okay
so physically it's a different picture
different views but they are all the
same thing
now few more discussion here sketching
point and first we discussed this small
K wave vector one is this in a crystal H
Park Hae right remember the we particle
duality is H over lambda is right h-bar
over K times K and this is a quarter in
crystal is called a crystal momentum and
without going into detail we can this is
the momentum when you think about doing
the energy conservation momentum
conservation right when two electrons
scatter with each other they still have
to obey energy conservation and they
still have to obey the momentum
conservation and the you see this is the
momentum that we'll be using and in 3d K
is a vector depends on different
crystallographic directions and also we
said that before this say K and the k
plus pi over a are equivalent that's why
we reduce this periodical representation
into only between negative PI over 2
plus PI or way and the what's really
striking is the gap right from this we
say there you see this region there's no
energy
there's no electron in the crystal can
have those energy and here similarly
there's no electron in a crystal can
have those energy
right so we have an energy gap okay and
then turns out that I say in real
crystals we have many different
directions
so maybe in one direction is this way
maybe in another direction the
petitioner is different right if you are
disagree this is a PI over a 1
periodicity in that direction and maybe
in the other direction is a PI over a 2
so it's not as if when I draw this I'm
drawing the other direction it's not a
negative I'm just drawing the other
direction okay and it might be you when
having possibility of this way okay and
if I say in some material it turns out
that there is a gap no matter what you
consider alterations
there's absolute the region where
there's no energy and this is the band
gap of the material okay
so energy gap and the extension is a 3d
is a bank gap okay now let's do a little
hunting and to say what does this mean
so I take my hydrogen one dimension of
hydrogen chant as example right
I put the electron so if I have a
hydrogen chain one dimensional hydrogen
chain that's here right and I am NOT as
spin now I have to add spin spin is
afterthought because my solution doesn't
include it right so each energy level in
fact that is the S Plus and park - right
bah wah - wah wah so there are two
quantum state now I put the electron you
liked wrong always anything except the
humans right like to go sit in the lower
energy State
right and spare illogical system me not
see humans see so I put the electron
they go to a lower energy state right
and if it's a hydrogen so there are an
electron each hydrogen has a wine
electron right between negative PI over
a 2 plus PI over a I have n points and
that means I have to end because the
spin I have to in quantum state so Pauli
exclusion say each quantum state has
maximum my electron and also the minimum
energy principle thermodynamics say or I
haven't bring in temperature but simmer
that I would say the electron goes to
lowest energy first so what happens is
ok now I have electron go here go here
go here and fill in here right because
it's 1/2 I have to in state I have n
electrons right so where electron feel
to the top is a is this point is the
Fermi surface Fermi energy Fermi level
ok so we have a Fermi level this is a EF
ok and now in this simple picture the
electron field to the 1/2 and now if the
temperature is not zero the electron get
a KT energy right in electron and the KT
energy those the electron maybe will way
below Katie they don't move
those electrons near the Fermi surface
they have energy KT and the energy
separation between this discrete small
levels are small enough so the thermal
energy can make them move to other
states right so electron can move in the
band
so those are medals right in medal the
fermi-level falls into the bands and the
metal
another every electron will be
contributing to the conduction Fermi
level is just a concept that we say if I
feel you were stopped most you feel you
never in the bucket where is that
surface there that's where they see
those are so electron only electron near
the Fermi level have a KT energy that
they can move run electron way below the
Fermi level right Katie the other states
is a field the Pauli exclusion principle
say no we I don't allow you there so the
electrons in this region they don't
contribute so you a metal you say you're
going to take a copper take a that is
constant you say per unit volume how
many electron but not all those
electrons will move will contribute to
conduction only the wires near the Fermi
surface okay no no I say I take it a
hydrogen example now I'm going to take a
teen you okay now what happens if I do
Heaney
where is it
so this is going to be here Kino has two
electrons right so I have to end States
I will fail through this region here
right what happened and that depends on
the gap here now
Katie 26 milli electron volts right 26
milli electron volts and if the gap is a
few electron volts five electron was
right so they are all filled and the
Katie can not lift the electron to here
there is a real forbidden region your
electron cannot have that energy so now
you have a gap and this is the RC in
that case if the gap is real
arge they say five electron volts it's
an insulator
it's a dielectric it's an insulator you
look at glass right the glass is an
insulator because there is a really
large gap and ready to go so photons
visible photon is 0.5 v 0.5 micron right
1 micron is 1.2 for I can't remember
which is with you when you're lectrons
one more point to 4 micron or the half
this is a 0.5 micron is about - some
electrons you liked wrong words okay
okay two electron volts the gap is much
larger so the light of all transmits
through the window they can lock the
electron from here to here they don't
have enough energy yes
okay okay that's it you're jumping good
good question I'm not that so I have to
go to more talk about some economics
right so semiconductor gap is typically
about the one to two electron volts okay
and and in that case there are some of
the thermal energy even though it's 26
and milli electron volts I have not
talked about the boards I mentioned
Boltzmann factor right so there's a
distribution of the energy thermal
energy summing electrons have enough
thermal energy very few they can jump
right if they have enough energy
thermally they can be locked up from
here to here so what happens okay I'm
talking about
that's a 1d example right here 3d is the
same I have a gap right so some electron
can be locked up from here to here
because if they have those electrons
having enough high energy compared to
the gap so what's going to leave behind
if I have a one more step one two
keenham right go to the Lex magnesium
three electron it has to go to the here
right the leg span and so the Fermi
level don't have to be Louis to what
it's just so you have to feel you look
at the periodic table you feel to the
top most there are many bands okay and
so when we have the let's say they I'll
take this simply one and turns out
sometimes
this is lowest this heist depends on
this is okay this is the where I do okay
I'm drawing a small region I can rejoin
here I can be doing here okay so now
this is my band gap this is Aug silicon
eg what is city-county eg 1.1 1.1
electron volt what's a goddamn ass
tonight
one point for okay so now the I have
some thermal energy so what it happens
is some electron Muirfield normally what
we lock the from the G to a higher
energy right so what left behind there
is some empty state so now I have some
empty states and I have some filled
States this is a conduction band this
valence band okay
conduction band valence band when Seban
has some some Lamptey states and
electrons are now suddenly in this band
again because the energy is so close to
each other those electrons can move
around right and this electrons filled
to the top now originally if I had zero
temperature they feel here they can't
move
right but now either some temperature
room temperature there's some empty
space left behind
so this electrons now they can move
around this empty space most of this
electron here sitting here they don't
move right so it's a one stone two birds
the electron move from here to here
electron can move here the empty States
also make the interested electron
happier when your lab is too crowded
that's a situation right and the guys
are moving the bigger room happy and the
guys left behind also happy that's what
happens to a lab and so those empty
States it's better than rather than
majority of the electron moving to ambu
States the opposite is those holes so
it's a positive charge so so there's no
hole okay it's just a charge it's easier
to describe those empty States as a
whole and this is the electron so we
have valence band
conduction band conduction band and
valence band and this is a valance
so you can say that you have to really
go to quantum to understand human the
basic why there is insulator
why there is a conductor why there's a
metal okay and now I thought I'm
debating whether I show this latter they
go to do our weekly exercise going to
the website are all going to continue
but an Emmy just because I think I need
to finish this so I'm going to skip that
this is the intrinsic semiconductor
there's always an equal number of
electron and the host right because the
wine electron go up and leave behind a
whole empty state now most of the time
you don't work with just an intrinsic
you actually put dopant right so what do
you do you'll put in silicon right if
you look at a city honk it has four
electrons
you put a phosphor so silicon is a
theoretical structure right for you like
Tron they all happy now rather than
silicon you put a phosphor here that's a
five right that extra electron can
detach it from phosphor and become
commonly sheared and so basically the
energy level of that phosphor is
somewhere here the thermal energy is so
high is lada enough to lift this
electron from phosphor to the conduction
band so in that case you put you dope it
that's called dopamine right you
artificially put the dopant you put the
phosphor that's the n-type you put a
boron which you have Syria backed wrong
whether it does so it turns out boron
energy level is here
and then say the electron is so happy to
see a closed energy level say once say
so so you will fall here you will see
Katie right so leave-behinds empty state
so you have holes so you dope you borrow
a little you get a pot as a host right
p-type you do blue phosphor you get an
end time right so that's the
semiconductor
that's an extrinsic so we have the
difference between extrinsic that's a
dope Ian and intrinsic is when you don't
dope here right and the intrinsic in
fact sometimes it's hard to make when
you purified silicon you can make that
pure and can amass an AI that could have
semi insulating substrate you when you
buy it that's because the bakar de
marsay Bhangarh is a one point four it's
a higher than one point one and so
there's very few electrons intrinsically
if you try to purify even though you
still have some your purities okay
there's another big difference here when
they when I when I have a dual here
between here and here right if the gap
is happening in different direction
right you have to look at different
direction I'm going to talk more those
two rationality if this is not at the
same point this is the momentum K
momentum here you like for whole
momentum electrons here goes there you
need a different momentum right there's
a change so that's an indirect
semiconductor silicon is indirect
semiconductor and a lot of cases it
turns out also the minimum a maximum is
the same place that's a direct gap
semiconductor carnem arsenide is direct
gap so you say it turns out the light
doesn't have much momentum if you think
about them as you see at your lambda
lambda for light is 1/2 micron
for Krister a is lattice constant is an
angstrom right so photon momentum is
very small so if I say when it's a drag
app you can easily excited because the
momentum conservation is easier because
vertical transition no momentum need it
but in silicon that's not easy because
it's going from here to here it needs
that momentum so it's an indirect
semiconductor and that's why the light
sauce lasers or made of gallium arsenide
if I say always people once they can I
make a light source with silicon because
silicon is so good for electronics it's
not good for optics right and that's
also reason why silicon doesn't absorb
well so when you make a solar sail
you have to make a very thick does a say
the chance of a light again when it gets
into the crystal get absorbed that is
not good so you make the thicker to
increase that chance okay yes
hydrogen missing my simple 1d picture
this is a this is here so it's a metal I
don't even call it the valence of
Kentucky it's a metal right this is my
conduction band right and helium here
right then you for that if I electron go
from here then this will balance this
conduction hi occupy yeah in fact when
you do molecule this is a called highest
occupied molecular orbital so when you
do see plastic solar cells there people
talk about homo and lumo because the
wave functions the wave vectors the
energy is no longer this continues it's
a sort of discrete then your language
actually was official homo and lumo
heist occupy the highest are not too low
song alpha pi okay
I'll make up for this slide so you're
looking at yours next week